made accused of shooting and killing a
metro police officer appeared in front
of a judge this morning Tyson Hampton is
being held with no bail in the death of
Veteran officer Trung Tai Candace
Charles was in the courtroom she spoke
with the district attorney about this
case
this didn't have to happen as with
district attorney Steve wolfeson said
following 24 year old Tyson Hampton's
first quarter appearance he's accused of
shooting and killing 49 year old metro
police officer Trung Tai now D.A Wilson
says he plans to put his best
prosecutors on the case and is
considering the death penalty now this
shooting happened on Thursday morning
according to police officer Todd was
responding to a domestic disturbance
around the one near Flamingo and
University Center when shots were
exchanged D.A Wolfson says Hampton was
armed and shot at Ty and another officer
they returned fire but Hampton ran off
officer's tie was shot in the Torso he
was rushed to Sunrise Hospital where he
passed away Hampton was taken in to cut
senior desert and in eastern he faces
multiple charges including murder and
attempted murder D.A Wilson says this
started with a misdemeanor domestic
battery and did not have to escalate he
hadn't engaged in the behavior that
caused the tragic loss of life to
officer Tom AI he may may have only been
arrested for a misdemeanor
and he chose to engage in this Behavior
which the evidence seems to show
Justified his arrest and probable
charges for murder with use but anyway
Hampton is inspected back in court on
Tuesday stick with us for the latest now
from the Regional Justice Center I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now